hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a 1997 American fantasy
family movie called The Borrowers which
follows the story of tiny-sized humans
against an evil attorney who plots to
destroy their house Pete son of a lender
family is setting traps throughout his
house as he believes there are tiny
creatures that cause stuff in his house
to disappear however his mother Victoria
convinces him that it is caused by his
and his father's clumsiness Joe lender
prepares to go to the family lawyer
OSHA's P Potter who will read his late
great aunt Mary that inherited the house
to his family feud also leaves for
school after the family has locked the
door small sized humans known as The
Borrowers appear from beneath the
floorboards they consist of parents pod
and homily clock and their children are
Yeti and P Green they only borrow things
from normal humans or beans as they call
them and keep themselves hidden and
unnoticed
to the lender's surprise Potter states
that Aunt Mary has left no will so they
have no right to own the house
Potter tells them that they must move
out as he will demolish the house to
make space for luxury apartments
powerless against the lawyer the lenders
have no choice but to obey meanwhile at
their house pod has taken A rietti and P
Green to go borrowing with him
his firstborn is a curious girl who
rarely listens to her father's warnings
despite his warning that a borrower
should stay unseen and unheard she
wanders around the kitchen with her
little brother pod borrows a battery
while she wants to grab an ice cream so
P Green assists her to go inside the
freezer and holds the door open
however he cannot hold the freezer door
for long slamming it shut and trapping
his sister inside at almost the same
time the lenders come home panicked pod
gives the borrowed battery to P Green to
be delivered to homily then he runs
across the kitchen to save arietti she
escapes through the ice dispenser hole
on the fridge but they are almost caught
when Joe dispenses ice they hold the ice
using makeshift sticks then Escape while
Joe is checking the inside of the fridge
back in the clock's residence beneath
the lender's floorboards pod and homily
scold are Yeti for being clumsy and
almost getting caught
she questions why they should stay
hidden especially since she has never
seen another borrower around the house
she believes other borrowers are
non-existent
suddenly they feel a trembling as
Victoria is vacuuming the floor out of
her usual cleaning routine in the
evening homily puts arietti to sleep but
she quickly becomes bored and decides to
venture around the house she observes
Pete watching TV in his bedroom
switching channels and comes across an
advertisement for a bug exterminator her
shock and clumsiness by the ads premise
caused one of Pete's toys to fall to the
floor alerting Pete about her presence
she is quickly caught and trapped inside
a bottle but learns that Pete does not
want to harm her as her parents have
warned feat learns about the borrower's
way of life but then tells her that the
house is being demolished and he will
move out he promises to help Arie Eddie
and her family to safety she then passes
the information to her family at first
pod despises his daughter's suggestion
but then agrees to be helped by Pete who
smuggles the whole family into their
moving truck he puts a walkie-talkie to
keep the clocks updated about the
situation along the road as Joe begins
driving the clocks become anxious due to
the excessive shaking they feel
however the truck hits the curb causing
an item to fall and making a hole
beneath the container arietti and pea
green fall through the hole landing on
the street
pot and homily become extremely panicked
and try to warn Pete through the
walkie-talkie feat tries to convince his
father to return to the old house but he
fails the clock children are left behind
so they return to their old house and
form a plan to catch up with Pete
Arrietty remembers directions to the new
house that Pete gave her earlier and
prepares herself and her brother for the
journey however they see Potter coming
to the house talking to himself that
Aunt Mary actually left a will for the
lender family but she hid it in a safe
somewhere inside the house because she
distrusted Banks Potter finds the hidden
safe and retrieves the will then calls
the city council to schedule an
appointment for registering a demolition
from the ventilation shaft Arrietty
thinks she can save the house from
Demolition if she can get the will from
Potter and deliver it to Pete meanwhile
Pete arrives at his new home and
immediately checks his stuff learning
that arietti and P Green have fallen
through the hole Pete picks up pot and
homily then rides on a bike to his old
house to retrieve Arrietty and pigri the
two attempt to take the will from Potter
and flee before he can burn it but
Potter notices the paper moving to the
ventilation shaft he closely listens for
the borrowers noises and cracks open the
floorboards attempting to capture them
he then enlists the help of Jeff the
Exterminator who uses special foam to
kill bugs and other creatures living in
cracks and holes throughout the house
after learning that Potter wants to
exterminate borrowers Jeff becomes
reluctant as he is fascinated by the
creatures but he still does his job
however they fail to capture the
children as arietti cleverly uses a
measuring tape to lift pea green to the
rooftop they then Escape safely through
the roof and glide to Pete's new house
using electric wires Jeff uses his dog
to track their scent but he and Potter
are suddenly interrupted by police
officer steady who thinks they are
trespassing on the lender's property
Potter assures that the property is now
his then officer steady backs away Pete
arrives in the old house and secretly
watches Potter and Jeff's encounter with
officer steady he goes inside the house
and discovers Potter's match after he
failed to burn the will pod learns that
his children are attempting to reach the
new house so they are probably still
alive arietti and P Green arrive at a
rooftop but Jeff's dog successfully
tracks them they are also startled by a
wild pigeon causing Peak green to fall
down the gutter and be trapped within a
milk bottle before Potter can pick it up
he is interrupted by Officer steady now
becoming fully suspicious of Potter's
weird movements while they Converse the
Milkman picks the bottle without
noticing Pig green inside then drives
off with his truck ariadi becomes sad
and concerned for her brother but
suddenly she meets Spud another borrower
unlike her who live sedentary in the
lender's house spot is an outsider or a
borrower living outside he takes area to
underground plumbing networks and drives
his aerosol paint propelled roller
skates so they can reach the milk
factory in note time meanwhile Pete sees
Potter chasing the Milkman and decides
to follow him
Peter arietti and Spud Potter and Jeff
all go to the milk factory ariadian Spud
get as close as possible to P Green an
attempt to extract him out of the bottle
but to no avail and raged Potter locks
the door so Peter anyone else cannot get
in then searches for the borrowers as
Pete is locked only pod and homily can
sneak inside the factory luckily Jeff's
dog is distracted by cheese his favorite
food so he cannot track the borrowers
anymore Potter smashes bottles at the
end of the machine line but arietti and
sputt Escape just in time before they
are also smashed Peak green is trapped
inside a sealed bottle but pod swings
inside the factory to break the bottle
and rescue him after the brief clock
Family Reunion where the family learns
that pod used to be an outsider Potter
quickly captures all of them he takes
the will for Mary Eddie and straps them
to the cheese tray Spud attempts to mock
him then Potter pushes him inside a
cheese maker he then sets the cheese
machine to drown the borrowers then
quickly leaves for the city hall Pete
encounters him but learns that the
borrowers are trapped inside so he runs
inside the factory to save them first as
he stops a taxi he hits Pete's bicycle
arriety tells him that he should catch
up to Potter to the city council to save
his home as his bike breaks down Jeff
approaches him with his truck changing
his heart to help Pete and the Borrowers
Potter arrives at the city council and
asks for directions to the demolition
room to register a demolition however
the clerk unimpressed by his arrogance
gives him confusing directions he
finally reaches the door to the
demolition room which turns out to be a
supply room
the borrowers have set a false sign at
the door and traps throughout the room
they work together to tie Potter using
tape but he escapes and recaptures them
as he attempts to use a vacuum cleaner
to suck the whole clock family other
borrowers suddenly appear tying him more
firmly from head to toe they turn out to
be Spud who survived the cheese machine
along with other Audis including pod's
longtime friends Potter exclaims that he
is not afraid of the borrowers but then
a whole village of borrowers appears the
clock family is Overjoyed to see they
have so much support pod gives a speech
to not mess with the borrowers then they
notice someone is unlocking the door all
the borrowers disappear as Pete Jeff and
off a steady end of the room finding
Potter standing still and still tied
Pete retrieves Aunt Mary's wolf from
Potter's pocket and gives it to officer
steady claiming that Potter has cheated
his family out of their house then
officer steady arrests him
sometime later the lenders moved back to
their house followed by the clocks now
aware of their existence Pete helps to
smuggle food and other necessities to
the borrowers living beneath his
floorboards the clocks are having a meal
with pod's longtime friends but Airy
Eddie and spuds secretly leave to ride
the roller skate meanwhile Potter tries
to explain to the police officers that
the borrowers catch him and describe
them but the officers only laugh at him
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching